>>> OUR BURIED LEAD NOW.
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL STIES WE
THINK ARE NOT GEING SUFFICIENT
ATTENTION.
FOR MORE THAN 30 YEARS THOUSANDS
OF U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES STATIONED AT THE
MARINE CORPS CAMP LEJEUNE IN
NORTH CAROLINA WERE EXPOSED TO
CONTAMINATED WATER.
AS CNN'S NICK WATT REPORTS
VETERANS AND FAMILY MEMBERS,
MANY OF THEM NOW WITH CANCER
DIAGNOSES POTENTIALLY CAUSED BY
THIS CONTAMINATION, WELL,
THEY'RE TRYING TO HOLD THE
MILITARY ACCOUNTABLE.
>> IF YOU WERE STATIONED OR
WORKING AT CAMP LEJEUNE --
>> YOU MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
COMPENSATION.
>> PLEASE GIVE US A CALL.
>> Reporter: YOU'VE PROBABLY
SEEN THE COMMERCIALS.
LAWYERS LINING UP TO HELP
VETERANS IN RETURN FOR A SLICE
OF A POTENTIALLY HUGE MONEY PIE.
HUGE BECAUSE THE WATER AT THIS
VAST MARINE BASE IN NORTH
CAROLINA WAS CONTAMINATED OVER
30-PLUS YEARS BY AN OFF-BASE DRY
CLEANERS, LEAKY STORAGE TANKS
AND CHEMICAL DUMPING.
1953 TO 1987.
POTENTIALLY HOW BIG IS THIS?
>> OVER A MILLION PEOPLE WERE
LIKELY EXPOSED TO THIS TOXIC
WATER DURING THAT TIME PERIOD.
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IN TERMS
OF DAMAGES?
I MEAN, IT'S OFF THE CHARTS.
>> Reporter: GREG SEXTON'S MOM
SAW ONE OF THE COMMERCIALS,
THEIR FIRST INKLING THAT CAMP
LEJEUNE'S WATER MIGHT BE TO
BLAME FOR WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM.
>> I SPENT THE
I WAS SPENDING TIME WITH MY
FATHER WHO WAS IN THE MARINES.
HE WAS IN THE MARINES.
WHEN I WAS 17, HE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH WHAT'S CALLED THE TUCHLER.
>> HE HAD KIDNEY CANCER.
ONE OF THE DISEASES POTENTIALLY
LINKED TO THE CHEMICALS IN THE
WATER ON THE BASE.
A BASE WHERE ANNE JOHNSON LIVED
WITH HER MARINE SERGEANT DAD
WHERE SHE MET HER FUTURE HUSBAND
IN HIGH SCHOOL, WHERE SHE GAVE
BIRTH IN 1984.
>> THEY DID BRING HER TO YOU
IMMEDIATELY, NO?
>> THEY DID NOT.
I GUESS THEY WERE TRYING TO
PREPARE ME FOR WHAT SHE LOOKED
LIKE.
>> ANNE'S BABY JACQUETTA LIVED
JUST SEVEN WEEKS.
AGED 18 AND FORCED INTO A
HORRIFIC DECISION TO LET HER
DAUGHTER GO.
>> I LOOKED AT MY HUSBAND, AND
HE JUST DROPPED HIS HEAD, NOT
KNOWING WHAT TO SAY.
SO I LOOKED UP AT THE DOCTOR,
AND I SAID JUST -- JUST LET HER
GO.
>> BIRTH DEFECTS NOW ALSO
POTENTIALLY LINKED TO THE
CHEMICALS IN THE WATER ON THE
BASE.
HERE IS THE HISTORY.
IN 1980, TESTS FOUND WATER IS
HIGHLY CONTAMINATED.
IN 1981, WATER HIGHLY
CONTAMINATED WITH OTHER
CHLORINATED HYDROCARBONS,
SOLVENTS.
THE MOST CONTAMINATED WELLS
WEREN'T CLOSED FOR FOUR YEARS
AFTER FURTHER TESTING.
IN FEBRUARY 1985, PCE, A
DRY-CLEANING SOLVENT, WAS
MEASURED AT 43 TIMES THE CURRENT
EPA LIMIT FOR DRINKING WATER.
HERE IN TARAWA TERRACE WHICH
HOUSES ENLISTED MEN AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
TWO DAYS LATER THE BASE
COMMANDER SENT THEM ALL A
LETTER.
TWO OF THE WELLS THAT SUPPLY
TARAWA TERRACE HAVE HAD TO BE
TAKEN OFFLINE BECAUSE MINUTE
TRACE AMOUNTS OF SEVERAL ORGANIC
CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN DETECTED IN
THE WATER.
NO HEALTH WARNING.
JUST TO REDUCE DOMESTIC WATER
USE BECAUSE SUPPLY WAS NO
LIMITED.
APPARENTLY A MASS HEALTH WARNING
DIDN'T COME UNTIL MUCH LATER, 14
YEARS LATER.
>> CERTAIN AREAS THE WATER IS
SUPER CONTAMINATED.
OTHER AREAS, IT WASN'T.
THE MARINE CORPS BARRACKS, THE
BACHELOR BARRACKS, THAT'S THE
AREAS THAT WERE TAINTED.
>> LARGE AREAS USED BY OFFICERS
AND ENLISTED ALIKE WERE
AFFECTED.
WHAT RANK WERE YOU WHEN YOU WERE
EXPOSED TO THE WATER AT CAMP
LEJEUNE?
96.3% OF RESPONDENTS SAY THEY
WERE ENLISTED.
3.7% WERE OFFICERS.
WORTH NOTING, THERE WERE ALWAYS
MORE ENLISTED MEN THAN OFFICERS
ON BASE.
AN ACT OF CONGRESS PASSED IN
AUGUST ALLOWS MARINES AND THEIR
KIN TO FILE CIVIL CLAIMS.
>> SOME SIMPLE ACKNOWLEDGMENT
WOULD BE MY WISH FOR EVERYTHING
MOVING FORWARD.
>> Reporter: THE NAVY HAS SIX
MONTHS TO PROCESS THEIR CLAIMS.
>> THEY'VE RECEIVED ALMOST 5,000
CLAIMS AS OF TODAY.
THEY HAVE NOT YET DONE ANYTHING
ABOUT ANY OF THEM.
>> Reporter: DO YOU THINK ANY OF
THE CLAIMS YOU FILED SO FAR WILL
ACTUALLY BE PROCESSED WITHIN THE
SIX-MONTH WINDOW?
>> AS OF TODAY, I DO NOT.
>> Reporter: AND IF NOT, CLAIMS
COULD END UP IN A COURTHOUSE IN
THE EASTERN DISTRICT OF NORTH
CAROLINA.
BUT LITIGATION COULD TAKE YEARS
TO EVEN GET INSIDE A COURTHOUSE.
>> IT REALLY COULD.
I THINK THEY ARE TOO WORRIED
ABOUT HOW TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
THAN FOCUS ON WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE DOING, AND THAT'S TO MAKE
THESE LIVES BETTER OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE SUFFERING
TODAY.
>> Reporter: RATHER THAN IT
BEING ME, THAT IT COULD HAVE
BEEN THE WATER THAT I CONSUMED,
AND THE GOVERNMENT COULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT I WENT
THROUGH, MY EX-HUSBAND WENT ON
TO REMARRY AND HAVE A COUPLE
MORE CHILDREN.
AND THERE WAS NOTHING WRONG WITH
THEM.
JACQUETTA HAD TO BE ME.
BECAUSE THESE OTHER KIDS WERE
FINE.
SO IT HAD TO BE ME.
>> Reporter: SO FOR ANNE JOHNSON
TO OFFICIALLY KNOW IT WAS THE
WATER, THAT WOULD BE A GREAT
COMFORT FOR HER.
NOW, THE NAVY UNIT HANDLING
CLAIMS TOLD ME THIS.
THE INITIAL STEP INCLUDES IN
PROCESSING AND ADDITIONAL
EVALUATION.
CURRENTLY THE NAVY IS FOCUSED ON
THIS STEP.
AT THIS STAGE, NO CLAIMS ARE
FULLY ADJUDICATED.
THE DEPARTMENT OF NAVY COMMITTED
TO RESOLVING ALL CLAIMS RELATED
TO THIS MATTER IN A FAIR,
THOROUGH AND TIMELY MANNER.
NOW THE MARINE CORPS DECLINED
OUR REQUEST FOR AN INTERVIEW,
BUT THEY TOLD ME THIS.
WE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS, VETERANS, CIVILIAN
WORKFORCE, AND FAMILIES,
INCLUDING THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED HEALTH ISSUES THEY
BELIEVE ARE RELATED TO THEIR
TIME IN THE SERVICE.
THE ISSUE HERE IS THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE RIGHT NOW WHO ARE
SICK WHO COULD USE THIS MONEY
RIGHT NOW, NOT IN FIVE YEA